okay people joining this live stream
this is part of our cycle of design
reviews for version 13.1 of awesome
language
and
uh
this morning this afternoon whatever it
is we are looking at um
control
and system modeling
so
uh where should i look at these things
which so
these things are source pages reference
pages
can i can i run them in a build yeah if
you have um
um
next kernel yeah
product i
built okay
has somebody checked that i have a
current prototype built
let's see
um
just check that
i hope i do
april 20th is that a pro is that the
right
time frame
yes so things should work maybe you
don't have all the latest maybe one or
two little properties made through an
error but okay all right
model predictive controller
you know one of these days we should
figure out how to make these things
actual internal links so i don't have to
retype the name every time
you can if you click that
dot
when you highlight that thing in my mind
no i know oh when i highlight it oh and
then i click the dot oh okay that works
yes all right
what is this creature right okay so let
me give you the backdrop and then
explain what this creature does so
um one way
to design a controller
is to basically optimize
for you know what are your examples
sorry where are the examples
they're closed the cell captioning not
available
yeah
um
[Music]
so
can i explain or do yeah yeah please go
ahead okay so one way to do that
is to sort of optimize
for
let's say that your goal is to get to
drive the signal to zero you know or
some constant value
so you want to do that
but use as little control effort as
possible because control effort costs
money basically
um
and
you know and and you can take into
account sort of unknowns otherwise known
as noise
of what can happen
um so it but but if you do that so
people have done that for very slow
processes they literally run an
optimization process that looks what's
going to happen many steps into the
future
like that they literally run an
optimization routine that does that
okay so just i'm still i'm i'm lost here
so we've got
this is a typical control system loop is
that a true statement yeah it's a system
that has some kind of internal state
that you have cons you know
yeah but i understand that but what
how contrast this with what what's its
of the functions that we already have
which is basically this is kind of like
this is a more sophisticated control
design than the functions that we have
for control design and so the the this
one
can take into account
uh variations that happen it can take
into con into account constraints
because in real life
you know systems are not linear like if
you have a plane for instance the
control surfaces can only go so far and
then i hit the limit
yeah okay so all kinds of real world
systems this is so complicated i mean
you know my question is really this
there are experts in this kind of thing
who presumably will understand what all
of this is
and hopefully we'll use this
well i think that this can can go
perfectly well into to uh courses and
and you know
kids to take their first control class
and stuff
where
i don't understand what
okay give me a scenario where
um
you know
let me have a scenario that that is even
vaguely a me type scenario so i'm not
controlling a plane
i'm i'm um
uh you know i'm i'm trying to um
i don't know i mean what's an example
where
uh
where this is realistically something
that i could use as part of some
workflow that i'm actually doing
um
well i don't think you've ever designed
a controller but
uh i i thought about it a few times and
i it got so complicated i gave up
well
yeah because you kind of validate it and
and and make sure it actually really
works and stuff like that
um well okay so i mean let's let's be
very basic okay the one that i was i was
going to do just for fun was control an
hvac system through a raspberry pi
through you know with um but i mean
that's
that was going to be some trivial pid
controller-like thing or something yeah
and so
um
no you can do that hvic system is a
perfectly
good example of that there's only so
much you can do
um i mean the control signals is limited
even in an hvic signal in a system well
okay you got a you've got a thermometer
and you've got um uh
you know and you've got a
a thing that can blow hot or cold yeah
and there's a maximum level it can blow
right and you probably can't yeah you
can't go negative
yes but okay so i mean is this if i were
going to do that in a very fancy way
using maybe extra signals like you know
the temperature outside or who knows
what else
could i use this
and walk me through how i would use this
i mean what what is the what is the
basic structure of the code that i would
write to for the hvac system
so whenever you do for and this goes for
almost all of our control designs which
is that you need a mathematical model of
the thing that you're going to control
how about if i don't have it how about
if i do i'm absolutely clueless i don't
know how you know so i i blow hot air
into the room i don't know how how
quickly it heats up
right
and so
then what people usually use is
is kind of a very
approximate model you might just do
um
you know like a
a spectral model you know like you you
you
you basically get a transfer function or
approximate transfer function
or
you
you don't you you try to do it model
less which means that you kind of tweak
parameters on
on a pid if you if you know nothing
about your system then there's probably
no point in trying to use anything more
sophisticated and i think it's better to
use something more generic
like an auto tuning pid
like we have okay so how would i do that
what's the function
uh pid tune
okay but i mean okay but so if i want to
write the whole
loop in other words i've got
so once you get the controller
you know how do i get the controller is
the controller a function or is the
controller what what is the controller
the controller is a dynamic system
that needs to be implemented
i mean the controller is basically it
takes in values from the thermometers or
whatever
and it puts out signals to the you know
to the heater or whatever yes
okay
and
that is typically encapsulated
in one of these kinds of of
transfer function models is that correct
yes
but then where do i put in i mean s
isn't that i mean this is a
representation of the model but how do i
feed in the value of the temperature
well that's the input to
that you know this
if you if you un if you click on the the
details and notes you can see where all
the signals are and you can get exactly
the thing that you want
but naively okay so so let's just say
that so the temperature is y
here okay that's the thing that you
measure
okay but but so just so i understand the
workflow here in the end
let's say you're doing it purely through
orphan language you're not arduinoifying
it or anything like that yeah then let's
say
um
you know every five seconds let's say
you sample with device
uh with our um
device read or whatever you sample the
value of the temperature
okay
then
you
uh and i feed it in somehow how do i how
do i store this thing has to know
presumably the time history of those
values is that yeah
yes but it it needs to not know the full
history it just needs to know as many
states as you have like say if you have
um
two states it needs to know two seconds
but i'm going to be very practical i've
got this raspberry pi thing it's been
measuring it every five every five
seconds it samples the value of
temperature yeah okay what do i do with
those temperatures
you you need to sort of remember them
okay and i do that system how should i
do that
how should i actually do it so i mean if
you build the input
the thing that generates code which is
our you know um
sort of microcontroller kit it takes
care of sampling them and all of that
but
if you have a con the thing that you
looked at has s there it's what's called
continuous time so that's a differential
equation you need to discretize it
first step but then you have basically
you can read off the difference
equations that you need to run the
recursion that you need okay so i'm
already totally lost so i mean i
understand that one approach is you make
an arduino and it is but arduino is like
has almost nothing to do with it you
could run it on whatever you want okay
but how do we do that i mean we've got
it you've got to take and we've
automated this that those steps that i
just described to you okay so then tell
me what i actually what piece of code do
i run on the raspberry pi
the code that's generated by what's it
called the deployment function
uh yeah microcontroller uh embed code
but but just to establish so if if like
a stevens thing you just want to do it
in mathematica instead of doing it in in
on on an external device that's what i
want to know yes
how do you do that so you take that yeah
so from pid tune or micro control or any
of these controller functions you get
that transfer function which is the
controller representation yeah and
you're going to do two discrete time
model that will give you the discrete
discrete version of that controller
and then you're getting these signals
from you know collecting these signals
through device read
now those signals are going to be the
input to this controller so you'll use
output response to get the response from
the controller and you'll take those
signals and feed it back into the system
you're controlling
lovely how do i actually do it
what do i do do i append values to some
list and feed them into the control
function or what do i actually do yeah
the device read functions those values
you take a window i don't know but you
don't take a window because they don't
have a way to take a window they just
take values right so what is our wrapper
what is our way to actually do this
right this this gives you if i'm not
mistaken this just gives you a value
value yeah right so what exactly do you
actually do
so of that value
uh is the input to the function i'm
aware but you've told me i need multiple
such values how do i keep the you know i
have to
and you have to keep a cyclic list
basically of how you know
you have to do that you're on your
is that correct we don't have a function
that does this
i have to build it myself yeah because
we don't think about implementing it in
in the wolfram environment itself you
think about deploying it to an external
because controllers are typically
deployed but you just told me that this
is doing an optimization loop
so that's not something which is going
to be deployed to an arduino you
interrupted me before i could finish
i know i did okay
if i can't finish telling you then i
won't tell you okay go ahead roger go
ahead but i mean i'm trying to
understand what this is
i mean okay here's my point of view
about this okay
i you know maybe this arduino thing we
have a deployment mechanism but this is
so freaking complicated
i mean it whatever i i can't believe it
needs to be this complicated
but go ahead get going i'm listening
tell me tell me how this works
well if you run an optimization program
each each sample it needs to be a very
slow process
so maybe your air conditioning system is
slow enough no
chemical processor chemical factors were
slow enough
in order to run it fast you you want to
pre-compute it so you don't have to run
an optimization program in the middle
of doing this
and this is what this one does this is
what's called explicit model predictive
control so this will actually generate
something
that can run
very fast that can be
you know also
deployed on microcontrollers
and other things
and
and
so so this is what this one allows you
to do this more sophisticated control
design that takes limitations into
account
and
uh computers you know beforehand so you
can run on even fast processes like
motion control needs to be fast for
instance
so the work the workflow is just like
pid tune so from pid tune we get a
transfer function which we have to
deploy or use it as i said in the vulcan
language
this one will have the same workflow
yeah this one you design something comes
out that's what you're gonna deploy
and here we're just simulating it the
closed loop system just
we're doing verification so where's the
example that shows deployment
there's no deployment here
okay but you will include an example of
that right
yeah we can do that
actually actually the microcontroller
deployment will be for 13.2 we don't
have that for 131.
this is more sophisticated so it takes a
little you know takes more effort to
to generate those
okay so
i mean
this function clearly has you know it's
just pages of stuff right clearly it
needs many many many many more examples
from this yeah it's in the school yeah
it's not complete but there are examples
in the scope and so on
okay i see that
but it's not it finished but okay
fair enough but but so
okay
um
so this is part of the the sort of hot
sort of control technology that people
expect to have um
um
and i've been asking for for that matter
and
i think that the biggest advantage is i
said it can take constraints into
account when you do the
design okay and
this this thing i'm making an explicit
one
it's it's as i said the biggest
advantage is that that can run fast
process if that needs to run in
milliseconds or microseconds it can not
a problem
the other thing needs minutes
i can't really help with this design
because this is you know deep inside an
area that i know little about
and
this is an unbelievably complicated
thing
so i i don't know how to you know i
don't really have much to say i mean i
don't know what
i mean you've got
a cost function that apparently has i'm
sure there are different norms for
applying the cost function
i mean i i guess my my only question
would be
you know we have a certain framework for
sort of representing things in machine
learning and reinforcement learning and
so on
and this is a completely different prong
a completely different community that
does control system stuff and we haven't
really done much to bring these two
together and maybe there's nothing we
should do because
it's incomprehensible to people you know
maybe it is the case that you have to
dive this deep
to be able to get anything to work
in which case it's really hard for me to
review this because i i don't know what
some
yeah i mean you know you've got
go ahead so when you're doing
reinforcement learning so in that
illustration that you see above right
yes we have so this page shows how to
compute that what you see in that green
box regulator
yep so in machine reinforcement learning
there's
just another
algorithm to compute
that regulator in a different it will be
a different regulator but a different
way and a different okay but is the
framework the same yes
yeah
but so so we can use you know transfer
functions and all that kind of thing in
in reinforcement learning is that
correct yes
so the same framework so i can have
instead of saying model predictive
controller i could say reinforcement
learning
system
and the same aspect cost and constraints
is that correct
i could i could it's plug compatible i
mean it's just a different algorithm we
don't have reinforcement learning no i
understand but the principle is the same
okay but so assume we were going to make
this
into i mean you know
is this
other than the fact that it doesn't
happen to use neural nets and so on
is the workflow of this the same as
reinforcement learning it could be if
you have
if you have a model of the environment
they call an environment there
yes then you can you can operate on it
and now because you can't really
and we need that that's a way to to make
reinforcement learning work is to have
environments that you can operate on
but i mean
wait a second i mean in
our existing reinforcement learning
stuff we've got things like
the
sort of models of of video games and
things like this that's a that's a
family of environments which you can
operate on yes yes okay right
so these are these mathematical systems
would be another family of environments
that people could operate but so what
we've talked about before is what the
api for those environments is and how it
plugs into the you know this no i mean
the reinforcement learning is going to
want its own
converters to set up that the
environment behaves like their formalism
wanted to behave okay
they're gonna mess around with it a bit
to get it to fit that framework right so
what i'm asking is all these lines here
okay
so you know
the thing we understand from our
language in general is there's a
function it's applied to arguments it
does its thing
and those arguments are always
represented as symbolic expressions and
we kind of understand what the overall
workflow of f of g of x is
okay what you've got here is a different
kind of workflow these are signals these
are functions over time yes i i know i
understand that but so what you're
defining here
is you know essentially a dynamic analog
of sort of function application which is
not function application anymore because
it has this dynamic loop right so what
i'm trying to understand is what is the
general thing
that
is that dynamic loop function evaluation
kind of thing
and isn't that the same kind of thing
between in particular reinforcement
learning and control systems and
probably other things too
yes
and so what i'm trying to understand is
you know what you've got here is a very
specific you know thing for specifically
for control systems built out in control
systems lingo et cetera et cetera et
cetera i'm trying to understand control
systems is a generic technology it
applies to a wide variety of fields okay
but then but i want to know so it's not
that specific i i understand that
let me just remind you just design wise
when we were first building manipulate
okay that thing was unbelievably
complicated it was full of
pseudo-variables and this and that and
the other and you know it's just really
messy
it took a whole bunch of grinding and
eventually we have something which is
very easy for people to understand
my question is and i've asked this
before in these meetings about control
systems i'm pretty sure that there's a
similarly easy to understand thing i
don't understand it but there's a you
know let me give an example the thing we
talked about about machine learning
could we make a generic wrapper that
says learn this function that wraps
around functions
i think jerome has has recently had a
prototype of this where he took an
inverted pendulum and solved this
problem and instead of regulator he has
a reinforcement learning controller
i hadn't seen the results of that but
okay but that's fine but but what i'm
asking is not
what the internal subroutines are i'm
asking what is the top level design that
represents this control loop basically
you see what i'm saying
because that's the part that i think if
we can get a really clean way to do that
that's
you know and it is a different thing
because it is something which like
manipulate manipulates a different
workflow from our usual you give input
you get output
right similarly this is a different
workflow from that
yeah but most of the controllers won't
live in mathematica that's like almost
no point in having a living mathematica
i understand that i don't care it's it's
the thing is to get something i mean
just like you could say a function f
i want to compile it okay it's now
compiled now it runs in you know a
machine code but it's still
the function f which i could call in top
level you know or language code
right it doesn't change its workflow
now
if if you tell me that this needs to and
and yes the function f
may have a different externalized
workflow than it has as an internal
workflow that's a that's an issue for it
but in this case
you know
if what you're saying is
this loop
all you're trying to do is produce
arduino code basically and this is
essentially a symbolic specification no
we we do put them together in in the you
know you put them together inside
mathematica as well and simulate them
together because you want to test things
before you go so to speak
so you you do put them together you run
simulations inside mathematica
absolutely
okay but but then
what i keep on saying it's the same
thing
is what you've got here is just a
function which
you know tells jokes by numbers so to
speak you have to know this whole
elaborate thing look at this no i'm
explaining it that's why i don't know i
i i understand but but look at all the
structure you have to build up
to be able to use this function
yeah but if you're gonna even specify an
optimization problem you specify as much
right or differential equation you
specify as much for sure at least
okay but but like this for example yeah
that's some whole complicated that
initial what is that initial sequence
there that thing what that thing there
that is some kind of order of the of the
state space model is that correct
yeah these are that's a different
situation
a bunch of different secrets okay how
would i have the slightest idea what to
put
well
there are many ways to get to that you
know you you can linearize you know if
you have another model you can linearize
it and get to that but yes that's very
hard to get to this is what we've
addressed
previously we've linked it up with
system modeler that you can use those
models of things
okay
just to understand if i change that one
to a two
yeah i've completely changed the plant i
i am the environment i understand i
understand but how would i know i'm just
coming in off the street how would i
know that i want listless list one one
zero one well that's the parametrization
of state space model you have to look at
the function
they take parameters right then this guy
takes matrices as parameters
okay but but so roughly do i know this
because i took a course in control yes
and they yeah they told me or you know
in the future that that page here i
don't know i don't trust these pages yet
until we work them over to become
learning pages
otherwise you could just read this page
in principle it's there but it might be
a little fast
see i don't understand this you know
write out okay you're not explaining
you're just giving
this weird thing here
and there's just no explanation
there's okay let's see if i can
understand it abcd
state matrix this
third cell explains what abcd i think so
this one here yeah continuous time
system modeled by the equations this
thing this thing this thing
and the next lane is for a discrete
system
okay so they're random coefficients in
that equation
i mean random wouldn't be a good model
no i understand but their coefficients
whatever
yeah modeling is hard we need to become
better at it
yeah
this is what i was um like let's say
differential equations how the [ __ ] do
you come up with the differential
equations and what we automate is d
solve and d so but
you can come up with a different group
that we have these kinds of names which
we finally have that we have for pdes at
least we're starting to have named
you know pde yeah we're building we're
building that but those named
i mean the domains i think is very
useful the named pde is not so useful i
think
really
yeah
why can't i okay if i know that i want
an integrator what is my workflow for
getting this can i go through system
modeler to get is there an entity that
represents
an integrator
that's a system model of an integrator
that i could like like like not yet but
eventually say control equals integrator
and i could get that integrated model
which i could then feed into the you
know either uses the state space model
or feed into the state space model
right so in our
molecule libraries we have a component
for integrator and then you can
linearize it and obtain a space test
model
okay but what i need to be able to do
is to go and type you know control
equals
integrator
okay we need to have linguistics so that
i can actually get to that system model
that way
i'm making sense because that's that's
otherwise otherwise you're asking me you
know otherwise i'm diving into some
giant
uh
you know browser adventure which is a
completely different kind of approach to
doing things
right how would i find the integrator
uh right so you could write a system
model and then uh integrator
really how would i know that
and then it's possible that you're going
to get several matches because we have
several components for integrator
but then you can just pick one up okay
but so what you need to do is integrate
it with the natural language stuff if
you've got a way to search for this
we've got to figure out how to integrate
that with our entities and so on am i
making sense
oh that's hopeless
yeah i mean you know it's hopeless
hopeless
it's because you get several i know but
that's no good we've already got a
framework for dealing with multiple
matches and it's not this but you're not
using it
right this is what i've been saying for
years right you've got to actually use
the framework that we have so you're
saying op-amps dot integra well where is
the generic integrator
that one there
okay now how do i get a state space
model from that digital system or rise
what's that
okay i lose
explain
um
that error message doesn't make sense
no this is the thing that we've been
seeing for some time that when there but
it's wrong it's not right i mean it's it
says continuous integrator right up
there
oh yeah
so this
i don't know something wrong it's not
this is no good guys this is like you
haven't you got to actually think how
people will actually use this stuff
right it's one thing to you know to get
something which works in a textbook it's
another thing to actually build
something people can use
and you know this is kind of comedic
come on we can do better than this we've
got a whole giant framework for dealing
with entities dealing with things like
this that doesn't involve some crazy
error message when we got multiple
matches
am i making sense
right
and you know this
is fine if i can get you know from
integrator i get the system model that's
beautiful right it doesn't work right
now but if it did work
and then
you know to say okay you linearize that
system model fine all good what would
you have expected to get out of that an
actual state-space model yes okay fine
so that's great
that seems like a great workflow
and it's impressive we have all the
components necessary to build it now
let's actually build the workflow to
make that work
okay so then then i'm going to get that
system model so i'm not typing this
weird thing here
and i don't have to say sampling period
which who knows where i know
you know what the sampling period is
supposed to be
i mean that's what
that's what your system is sampled at
i understand what it is but i'm just i'm
just asking how do i know if i'm trying
to model my hvac system for example
and you know all i know is i've got a
thermometer i've got a you know a thing
i can change the temperature of those
are my two things i can control
and
you know and i didn't take a control
systems class
do i have any hope of using our stuff or
is it hopeless
do i have to dive into
you know state space models of this and
that and the other of um
you know lq something or other things
and it's that's like hopeless because
not not end user usable
so i don't think that the pages are
written for someone that doesn't haven't
taken a class at this point they're not
learning pages okay the functionality is
not designed you need basically a
an intro class to control
okay well fine so i mean it's like so
but it's like 101 that's the thing you
take in sort of year two or something
right if you're doing linear algebra and
you're diving into qr decomposition
that's not going to be done by the
person who just knows what a matrix is
that's going to be done by somebody
who's taken a numerical analysis class
yeah but but even linear algebra you
probably need to have a class on that um
well i understand but if you've if there
are
people who will use
you know basic things with matrices okay
you're right that all these things need
some amount of understanding
i mean it's coming in earlier and
earlier in that case unfortunately but
but so i mean what i'm asking is can we
take all this stuff
and make it so that there is a flow
where there is a reasonable chance that
somebody who doesn't have that there is
a pretty good flow i mean okay
stephen there is but these pages haven't
been rewritten to be sort of learning
pages and and basically do the course
for you
um
but the flow in the terms of the flow
that we have it's not bad
it's it's it's it's you know look i'm
looking at this it's i can see what it
is right
it's kind of complicated
now maybe you're telling me it has to be
complicated maybe you're telling me
there is no model i mean it's just like
like
you know
in recent times i've been re-looking at
all these mathematical logic things okay
i could take what we do
in pattern matching transformation rules
for symbolic expressions things like
that i could write that in mathematical
logic ease
okay nobody would ever understand it
or almost nobody you know six people on
the planet who are experts in those
things would understand it
they will be unusable
but the fact is you know if you look at
like like you can describe the way we do
pattern matching for example you can
describe that in terms of you know all
kinds of
concepts in mathematical logic and so on
and you can define you know the fact oh
we've got a an operator and a variable
and this and that and the other thing
we've got 17 differently named things
turns out they're all just represented
by you know x blank
okay but it takes effort to turn it into
something where you're just representing
it in terms of x blank instead of just
copying the textbook
and what i'm suspicious about but i
don't know this field so i can't really
tell i'm suspicious that we're in the
copying textbook phase we're not in the
grinding this down to the point where
we're actually getting the essential
things that we can do
given that we have you know symbolic
representation of arbitrary expressions
et cetera et cetera et cetera
that's that's my point and my objection
here
i'm making sense i mean i you know i i i
can't do it because i don't know this
field what we haven't done right now
stephen is to throw away all the work
that was done before
right
the years of work that put into control
system before and start over and say
we're going to design a new way of
thinking about control systems that
nobody has ever heard of we've not done
that i know it's the same thing that
look it's the same reason if we provided
a system
that used mathematical logic
it just said we're going to go full
mathematical logic we're going to have
de bruyne indices we're going to have
you know i'm familiar with it it's sure
right sure right we're going to we're
going to do you know oh you you don't
you don't think we're going to have a
function function we're going to have
eta reduction instead yeah
nobody studies that logic at the
elementary level this control systems is
basically elementary courses
this is a difference
you know well okay so that that you're
saying
that okay this is broadly applied this
is broadly used and taught
okay well i'm just not in its target
market so i can't no right right so i
mean that's that's some uh and nor would
i be in the target market for data
reduction
right right
but see
that stuff you know that's like one of
those classes with four students in it
yes you know it's it's a very different
uh niche i'm saying like like
you know people come to us and ask for
things sometimes which you could say
that it's like irrelevant like think
about all those
named hypothesis tests
sure
um that's kind of silly well okay so i i
hate those things but i will ask for
yeah i know i will i will say the
following thing about them
they are cognitively straightforward
that is once you know what a hypothesis
test is
having
you know joe's hypothesis test and
bill's hypothesis test
is not cognitively you know it's just
like saying once you have the concept of
an entity that represents a chemical you
might as well have 20 million of them
so to speak
the difficulty here is that there's a
lot of structure that you have to you
know this is similar in all the design
functions it's similar it's the same
structure
okay well that was that's helpful the
thing is you know part of what's
difficult for me
okay so like i just don't know how to
start here
yeah i don't think that that's super
easy that's why we put effort into
building bridges to um we have the best
modeling system in the world for god's
sake yeah system modeler is the best in
the world
so that's why i'm saying this workflow
and i think this will be great
okay if we can smooth this workflow this
will be great
but you know we tripped twice here
wow
you know this needs to work
if if we make this workflow work it will
be great
okay and this thing is just a bug
yes
so
you know in any case okay let's go back
to this we're going to run out of time
so let's go back to looking at this i
mean i'm not sure that i can help you
very much on this this is a no i
understand that it's sort of just just
that the workflow is exactly that the
sort of outside workflow you have a
model
you can give sort of design specs which
are goals
and you can give constraints
you let the algorithm churn and it will
compute you and will give you an optimal
controller
is exactly the same way that all the
other controllers interact with your
system
so the thing is going to generate a
i can't
see it okay system connections model
systems connections model now it's that
it's the one about that that is
generated
so all our controllers now controller
data yeah
and that from that this is what we
automated so you can get all these
things in one yeah putting those like
closed loop system if somebody had to
manually do that that's yeah
you guys are so close to having
something really nice
i just think there's i i just think
there's more to understand about how to
do this
you know
maybe not i don't know maybe um
uh maybe there's no choice
i'm not saying you're wrong stephen i'm
just saying that we didn't decide
something odd and we didn't throw away
what we have
no i understand that we didn't design
something odd that people don't
recognize
this is one step forward to say this is
not standing still this is the modern
control systems this is what
people been asking to be able to use
why do we need to do something like this
evaluate list data
yeah because it's hold also otherwise it
won't just return an empty plot
no we need to discuss that we need to
discuss that we need to discuss that
mechanism i don't think that mechanism
is right it's a much bigger issue
that has
whatever
um
all right well so
what is the comparable to this function
what is the other thing that you can use
you know if i were is there a plug
compatible thing that doesn't contain
those constraints is that right or not
what is it
yeah the the younger brother of this is
lq regulator gains lq regulator gains is
almost the same except that it doesn't
have a construct why does it have a name
that has nothing to do with the name of
this function
which one well it's called lq regulator
games
called such and such controller well i
think we should rename them controller
to be honest
that's a more correct name that was an
old name that you guys decided on a long
time ago who's the you guys you and
peter overman
my god
okay
what seems wrong i mean if if it's in a
family of controllers why on earth is it
yeah we're planning to actually rename
all this to controller
so what would it be called later what
will it be called in the lq lq
lqr lq controller yeah oil cube
controller
okay
and so then it will take it's right now
i'm seeing spec
cost constraints yeah this will take
spec and cost weights here this the same
same thing we just use different
symbols weights and costs are the same
okay
okay so this diagram is the same the
same as this diagram yes
except it is really the same
is that what you're telling me
yeah it it is the same i'm going to
actually redraw that so it's going to be
the same
okay yeah it says it it's just kind of
complicated i mean again this all really
helps to make you know by the time it's
a herd of controllers i'm much more
motivated to learn how each one works
yeah
how many other ones are there
yeah
and so they're all star controller is
that correct
no
i mean they will be they will be
um
why were they called gains before
because they were
doing something a little bit simpler and
they were just basically a linear gain
because in that simple case that they
solve
the controller is literally just a dot
product a linear gain
i see but the packaging that we will
eventually have
is that every one of these will return a
systems model controller data yeah
exactly
when we change the name right now you
have to give an additional property to
get that data but by when you change the
name the plan is to just by default
return this controller data for all and
that gives you the nice workflow well
that is a much better workflow yes i
mean listen listen it really helps to
have a heard of functions all not you
know all
we're just very limited man
right we have a little bit limit we're
very limited bandwidth
you know for controller control
development
so
well okay but i think you know okay so
coming in in steps
okay
well again this function i mean if
you're confident of this roger i i just
can't i just have nothing to say i just
don't know what a quasi feedback gains
model is
you know i mean i can learn all these
things but i just don't know this stuff
so
now let's just look at what else you
have on the agenda here i mean this is
just a good output model
what is that so there are two
fundamental ways that you represent
dynamic systems one is a state space
model and one is an input output model
okay
and an in an input output model it just
uses inputs and outputs and writes the
recursion equations or the differential
equations in those terms
discrete means discrete time here
and so
um
look at that function look at the um two
is it the name we want to use for this
this is this is deep inside the control
systems world but that name does not say
that
yeah okay so i might say control model
or something
because
we want we would like yeah following the
precedent we would name it like discrete
systems systems model right okay
but we wanted to we wanted to actually
change all systems model to input output
so that's why
we're transitioning to this new name but
i don't think that's right because
see the problem is by the time you name
it this
our whole system is about input output
but these functions specifically aren't
they're about a feedback mechanism but
they're not called model the other
things so this
we call it state space model right this
is input output model those are the two
fundamental things there are
all right you know and transfer function
is just a
special way of giving an input output
model for linear systems what do you
mean by input output model
it it
in the model there are only inputs and
outputs and previous in the discrete
time previous shifts of those
okay
um how do you see the shift where are
the i mean
how do you give
output at sampling instant i
there are examples
i like your hand-drawn diagrams
they have a certain style it's nice um
okay in any case um
a simpler example start in scope but
this is just a summary
so now you can see the output response
say you feed it at an input sequence
what's the output sequence what's the
response to that input sequence
i see
and that's representing some kind of
thing with differential equations or
something well difference equations in
this case so this is like sample
differential equations
okay
so it's like so compare this with like
an armor process
yeah this is basically an armor process
i actually show that in properties you
can represent an arma using this
okay but so but but how this this one
allows for non-linear stuff okay arma is
just linear
okay i mean
those functions do they have
kind of a correspondence i mean if i
okay so if this was a linear function
then i could make an armor thing out of
this right
if this was just look i could just make
a
a trivial
so here's the assumption for arma so for
control system you need an r max
arma x
x means exogenous input
okay uh like you have an arx
it's an auto regressive means it's
operating on its own tail so yes
right
um
so so arma and ar and so on they assume
that you only have basically white noise
driving them
okay okay but this this one's like in
control systems you have both white
noise and control
driving your process
okay
so yeah okay so this thing go ahead no
we didn't do when we did random
processes
we debated whether we should do the
build out to exogenous input support
the as is relevant for control systems
we didn't do that we start with arma we
didn't do our max
which i'm saying okay there's a whole ex
exogenous input family
okay
this will be
improved in the next version there's a
deeper there's a mild there's a mild
improvements
okay this was the thing i was
complaining about before about caching
yes but that's that's there's a lot of
deeper bugs being fixed and and built
right now that's going to make it okay
so look just
you know i think it will help a lot to
rename these things so we don't have all
these rat you know if it's all a star
controller family and so on that's
really going to help we will do that for
13 too
okay
i think also
the
you know
getting this workflow to really work so
that
and you know we know we need to get rid
of the system model examples thing and
replace that with a more generic
uh you know essentially repository
browser
right
now i'm just trying to understand has
any work been done
on getting linguistics for these
entities and so on
no i was going to organize that but then
you organized it and i don't know what's
then happened
no i didn't organize it well you called
me into some meeting about that uh
but then you know i said find and i'm
not doing it
but we can grab a hold of it yeah you
should you should be doing it i mean i i
offered some resources for people who
know about linguistic curation
that's about it
okay that's because nobody knows that i
mean somebody
you know
it's some
uh
okay
because i mean i think
i think if we can make this workflow
work i mean unless you think this
workflow is silly for some reason but it
doesn't seem silly to me
you know that we have to work through it
and i'm sure we'll find
useful
um
scenarios for which it works yeah i
think that what will happen is there are
a lot of obvious named things for which
it should work
then there are things where it's a whole
complicated story
right i mean it's also things where you
know if you understand the
disambiguation mechanisms
you'll be able to
you know deal with this with just the
generic dot dot
disambiguation okay to deal with this
case
and
you know i mean what's an example give
me an example
from you know
system model
you know if i say
give me a bulldozer
okay clearly there's a great diversity
of bulldozers
but it's great diversity of almost
everything like i know if you ask for an
electrical motor it's the same as asking
for like a like a motor like like an
engine it's like
some engines in the world okay so if you
ask for a hamburger
okay
yeah there's also lots of kinds of
hamburgers
that's true
and so we've got a whole mechanism for
dealing with you know
uh well this is a generic hamburger
because we happen to have the concept of
a generic hamburger but but we have a
whole mechanism for dealing with all of
this stuff
right
that goes you know so i suspect this
particular thing i don't know what's
another kind of food um
a pie
okay i don't know what that's going to
do that's going to
say
um
food type okay so i think
the yeah these are these are these are
obviously very generic foods how many
calories in that pie
that's a good question i don't know we
can say um
huh
my god
well the question is why
it's
you know why it hasn't disambiguated why
there isn't more disambiguation here i'm
confused by that
before it will before it will give you a
nutritional label so to speak
but there may be some who knows that
maybe some world standard of of um
uh
um
i mean i don't know what's it i didn't
even know that that's what i meant when
i said pie
but it's interesting that's an
interesting
it's a look it's a pretty decent model
for what you're trying to do
okay
a food type okay i don't know what this
is going to do here
for food type
um
i'm surprised that this doesn't give
more
um
more disambiguation immediately but the
point here is this is the mechanism you
should be using to disambiguate
bulldozers and things in my view
and um you know there are many purposes
for which
sort of having the generic bulldozer is
already useful
and there are other purposes for which
you need to know tremendous details to
do anything useful no you're right and
actually that's how the libraries kind
of
actually work in their own right for
components and stuff
fine
i think i think you should just follow
the way it's done for food it's pretty
well developed although i'm a little
disappointed that this
and um i don't know who's who's here
from project management
i'm here from project management kristin
okay so please take a screenshot of that
send it to michael ask him what the heck
that is yes i will
um
take a screenshot um
okay well we should wrap up here but
okay sorry sorry i couldn't be more
helpful i mean i'm just i'm trying to
i i want us to sort of you know i wanted
to get this
control systems is really quite simple
control you know it's like it's obvious
you you we all do it ourselves
we just need to um yes but i i claim
there's
smoothing of the you know
the sort of exterior of the workflow
that will dramatically help in making
the thing not
just seem like
you know oh you have to go and study
every detail of this to be able to use
it because the thing that to me is going
to be exciting is when we can take
something like i mean just like we can
take machine learning which could be
very complicated but we can take eta
reduction let's say which could be very
complicated and we can consumerize it to
the point where you can use it even if
you're not an expert on that
to me this isn't to that point
i could imagine no it's not i mean we
built elements of it like pid tune is
one of those consumer-ish things and
we're moving same other workflows on but
there are more tales right but i mean
but but you know the question is could
we write something
where i don't know when when we are
trying to do something about um you know
server configurations or something which
could use control system i'm not sure if
it can
but um
uh
uh
you know just like just like you know
can we actually use our queuing theory
system to deal with
stuff to do with load balancing
you know that hasn't been tried yet we
may have to try it
um but that's the real that's the place
where as far as i'm concerned you know
if that works then you know it's good
we've got a uh
you know
a well usable workflow if it doesn't
work then you know it's um once i'm
happy all right we should wrap up here
okay thank